tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo video
sono fatti j
noi ci siamo su costi in mese un tunnel
da nel tunnel va bè ragazzi non è un
videogame ma sarebbe una sorta di
fumetto coreano horror breemen circa un
paio d'anni fa non mi ricordo
precisamente ne avevo fatto uno simile
dove mi hanno preso un jump schera
adesso io non so se questo ha dei jumps
che prego il dio di no però se se così
in toto ski tutto in corea non si
capisce una mazza
vabbè io registro e lo leggo tanto che
dovevo leggerlo per i cazzi miei
faccio spengo la luce che magari ha più
ha più senso way si è bello che bello
perfetto vedo che sono anche a casa da
sola fantastico agostin mese un tunnel è
stato diversi anni fa era sulla strada
di casa da sola su un autobus che già
già già già sta cosa mi fa che prende
malissimo
c'erano soltanto 10 o meno passeggeri
seduti qui dopodiché è l'autobus entrò
in un tunnel circondandoci completamente
nell'oscurità
ho lasciato che i miei occhi si
staccassero dal quaderno che stavo
leggendo sull'autobus per ammazzare la
noia nel ritorno a casa
oddio cos'è oh mio dio e non è passato
molto prima che mi addormentasse dovevo
essere molto stanca
più dio diverso tempo è passato aperte
negli occhi e fuori dalla finestra
eravamo ancora nel tunnel e le luci
rosse continuavano ad apparire
continuamente ma non importa quanto
l'autobus potesse andare lontano
non c'era fine al tunnel sembrava che
qualcosa da fuori in questo mondo mi
stessi circondando dandomi il senso di
sconforto e paura
avevo i brividi su tutto il mio corpo
così mi sono appoggiata al corridoio per
riuscire a vedere meglio l'interno
e tutti i passeggeri sembravano essere
addormentati lasciando cadere il loro
corpo di lato ma comunque non riuscivo a
vedere bene lo stesso a causa dei sedili
mi sono girato per vedere d'altra parte
dell'autobus o mio dio e ho visto alcuni
passeggeri che giacevano sul pavimento
con delle ferite mortali sui loro corpi
e stavano sanguinando copiosamente una
terribile sensazione attraversato la mia
mente quando improvvisamente un sono
misterioso è arrivato da davanti
oddio
oh cazzo oh mio dio c'è uno con una
mannaia
in apertura lo sapevo che si gira lo
giuro non lo stavo per dire lo so perché
i ragazzi guardate che so che si g non
ho fatto in tempo a iniziare la frase
che non sapevo che bello ciao
beh dai non è male è carino da quel
momento non mi ricordo esattamente dal
panico continuato a premere la via
cintura di sicurezza per sganciarla
finché non mi sono rotta un'unghia ma
oddio no ti prego la mia cinture di
sicurezza non si è mossa di un
centimetro e qualcuno ricaviamo a tutto
anche alla scrivania bene mi chiama è
crollato il computer dove cazzo el ma
ecco definito il ma il mouse cielo di
qua è finito la ciao ciao vedi che mi
saluta perfetto il coltello del bambino
del bambino ti sembra come cazzo fai
solo un bambino questa roba il coltello
del bambino arriva direttamente alla mia
coscia provocandomi un dolore
incredibile e facendomi perdere
conoscenza e la madonna si è svegliata
mi sono svegliata ritrovandomi in una
corsia di ospedale dovrebbe esserci
stato un incidente
i telegiornali continuano a riportare
questi tipi di incidenti ogni giorno
incidente di un autobus nel masoud
tunnel
otto sono morti e vabbè il cui incluso
l'autista lasciando soltanto me stesso è
un altro passeggero vivi e indoviniamo
chi è l'altro passeggero ragazzi 6 amica
un bambino la gente ha detto che sono
state in coma per due giorni con seri
danni alla mia gamba
poteva andare molto molto peggio hanno
detto sono sopravvissuta grazie alla
cintura di sicurezza che mi ha protetto
e non mi ha fatto uscire dal
dall'autobus quando c'è stato
l'incidente ho provato a convincere i
dottori l'infermiere i poliziotti ad
investigare per quanto riguarda il
bambino che ho visto sull'autobus ma non
è un bambino
vabbè ma nessuno sembrava credermi
un altro sopravvissuto è ancora in coma
e si trova nella corsia di fianco alla
mia devi per forza andare via
questa persona probabilmente potrebbe
aver visto che cosa ho visto io
sull'autobus
ma non è il bambino grazie a dio è una
roba tipo no no no no no no non ascolta
zio ha scritto the latino tela tiro non
ha fatto cazzo bene benissimo va bene
così c'è una famiglia sepolta sulla
montagna di seok sung localizzata jong
si g nigido decapitati alla morte a
causa di una falsa accusa come traditori
del rap guangxi
uno di loro era soltanto un piccolo
bambino che sapeva solo dire poche
parole lo spirito di un bambino piccolo
sembrava essere un cadavere ambulante
per niente questo se ne va in giro con
la mannaia fantastico guang qi ha
piazzato una grandissima pietra sul
prato dove la famiglia è stata sepolta e
il bambino fantasma non è mai più stato
visto il maso un tunnel dove è successo
l'incidente si trova a metà si trova
veramente li ok perfetto
sì però adesso mi salta addosso deve
saltarmi addosso per forza a me ne sto
andando fantastico ok no non me ne sto
andando è successo e succede qualcosa no
fine come fine ma non può finire così ma
dai ma che ove si è girata c'è un
continuo dai ragazzi è finito così è
stato strano però figo cioè mi piacciono
si racconti del terrore mele lynch ray
prima di andare a dormire ste cose una
cosa è certa ragazzi che non ho ancora
capito dove minchia ce lo vedono il
bambino in questa roba e non importa la
chance di microfono cercare un'altra
volta li mortacci sua
vabbè ragazzi fatemi sapere se vi piace
che io faccia queste cose molto horror e
fatemi sapere se vi è piaciuto se ne
volete ancora io continuerà nel prossimo
episodio se ne farò altri consigliate il
bambino sei [ __ ] il mio telecomando
dove cazzo è la prova senza se vi do è
piaciuto da software momento è un mi
piace
lasciate un mi piace perché il bambino
lo merita
non meritava il mi piace stata bella
faccia dei ragazzi seguiti è piaciuta
assolutamente mi piace anche a faccia di
facebook e come noi video tratta una
descrizione sono diversi discreto che ci
viviamo castro voglia è saltato tutto ci
sono anche le pile volete le pile bene
beh ragazzi